mr. big chest aka Antonio Brown has made
maximum use out of social media this
year as he has tried and succeeded in
getting his way out of Pittsburgh and
will eventually be a member of the
Raiders and he's apparently in Oakland
he had this message for anyone paying
attention on social media earlier today
I'm the Oakland California to parasite
it
animal clothes I know I'm going to
facility at eight o'clock I'm gonna
scream be grateful decide to get to the
facility I meet all the cultures decide
to see mr. grueling
working down with DC later twelve
o'clock it's gonna be a great day man
we'll keep you guys updated
I'll stay tuned look there's a couple of
problems with what Antonio Brown said
there first of all he hasn't been traded
to the Raiders yet and second of all he
apparently doesn't have permission more
importantly the Raiders don't have
permission to do anything other than
give him a physical if he's going there
to work out if he's going there to meet
coaches if he's there going there to do
anything other than take a physical the
Raiders may be straying beyond what they
are entitled to do and it wouldn't
surprise me if ultimately the Raiders
say to Antonio Brown maybe we should
wait you know a day until this trade is
finalized and also from Browns
perspective whether he's working out at
the Raiders facility the Steelers
facility or anywhere else not a good
idea to take any risk with your body for
now because if you suffer a serious
injury by some fluke some accidents some
coincidence something that would cause
you not to be able to play this year
you're not getting traded you're not
getting the new contract you're not
getting anything this year so Antonio
Brown be careful be smart be patient
you'll be a member of the Raiders soon
enough
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports